hey everyone i'm lucy and i'm a
solutions architect working at amazon
web services
and i'm carol and i'm a software
engineer at canva and today we'll be
talking about
how to get a job at tech after
graduating university
yep that's right so first of all we're
going to be going through how to find a
job that you're interested in
where and how to apply for jobs to
maximize your chances for getting an
interview
and finally we're gonna be sharing some
tips and tricks on how to do well in the
interview process
but before we get started make sure you
visit carl's channel to see a video we
made on the difference between
information systems and computer science
this will be great for students who are
deciding between the two degrees and not
sure what the difference is and
which one to study for okay so to start
off with we're going to be answering
three rapid fire questions
so caro what did you study in university
i studied computer science
and i studied information systems second
question is what do you like most about
working in tech
what do i like the most about working in
tech i would say
it's the creative freedom you have with
all the skills you can do whatever you
want
yeah i agree with that i think also in
tech as well it's very fast paced and
there's a lot of innovation happening so
very exciting
and the final question we have is what
is the biggest piece of advice you have
for students interested in breaking into
tech in 2021
i think just be yourself and listen to
your heart
especially in the interview process it's
all about being yourself and showing
um what you're actually like and the
skills that you can bring so yeah that
would be my piece of advice as well
okay let's start with the first part of
this video which is how to find a role
in tech
after university that you're interested
in and we're going to be sharing a bit
about our personal experience as well
trying to navigate this whole process of
job interviews
and just try to figure out what sort of
roles we want to go into after
university
so carol i know you interned at
microsoft and now you're working at
canva and it's been
almost i think it's been just over three
years right i can't wait
yeah so very exciting so how did you
figure out what you wanted to do after
university so now you're an android
engineer
and i guess how did you sort of realize
that this was the path that you wanted
to take
so actually my android journey started
before university
um i was like creating websites since i
was a kid i was making like a puzzle
websites for my friends to play
and like really quickly i realized like
the limitations of
web which was mostly internet uh speed
and like back then which was probably
like 10 years ago
you didn't really have much internet on
your phone like internet data
so android was a way to get over it
which is like you can have everything
offline
and always with you and i think that was
the part
of like the android development that was
like really interesting for me that you
can
always have your apps with you so that's
how it started
and then through university i actually
thanks to some
of the apps i created before joining
university i got some
part-time jobs doing android engineering
and then whenever
i got into like some different fields so
i did some back-end i did some web like
i never really
liked it as much as i liked android so
that was kind of
a confirmation for me to just keep doing
it
and yeah that's what happened yeah it
sounds like this journey started
like very when you're very young so you
kind of figured out your interest quite
early on which is
really fortunate which is good but it
also sounds like you've got some
experience
throughout your time at university to
try and figure out if you actually
enjoyed it and
you would actually consider it as a
full-time career so i think similar with
me as well i was interested
in tech at quite a young age but i think
i wasn't really
sure what specifically i wanted to do
though after university because i
realized that there were so many areas
on tech and
i was interested in so many different
aspects and i guess the reason i decided
to become a solutions
architect towards the end i think it's
just because during my internship with
aws i got a chance to talk with people
in a lot of different roles within the
company
and the solutions architect role seemed
like a perfect mix between
being able to talk to customers and
being able to build solutions for them
what would you say would be
the tip that you would give to students
who are not too sure yet what they want
to do after university like they're
interested in tech just like us but
maybe they haven't had as much exposure
with the industry
i would say just figure out what
interests you
just look around look around at like
apps that are existing and when you feel
like oh
this is really interesting like i wish i
knew how to do it just try to copy cut
it
and then also if you are still at uni
uh take all the courses that seem
interesting so for example i was really
really interested
in like what is machine learning during
uni so i took this course i loved it
but after it i was like this is not what
i want to do so
sometimes you get also the confirmation
that something is not
the direction in which you want to go
but it's much better to just take one
semester of it than
go and get a whole new job or or a whole
new like a master's degree doing it
so yeah i think that's it yeah that's
interesting
it's like sometimes the courses that we
can do gives us a taste of what it would
be like
um learning more about it and
considering it for a career
i think um very similar to that the
advice i was gonna give was related to
internships
because you do it for maybe like eight
to ten weeks so you get a trial
to see if you like it or not and if you
do you can continue on
as a graduate um in maybe in the same
company and same role doing it
you can always look for shadowing
opportunities so when you're in the
company you can ask to shadow them
and listen in on their meetings and that
way you can sort of get a better sense
of
whether that job is right for you that's
a really good tip i think internships
are really important and don't make my
mistake and do the same internship in
the same place in the same area twice
because it's just a waste of time and
waste of experience like you can only
get
as many internships so use it wisely
just try
things that are as different as possible
i think that's um yeah time is really
limited
university when we think about it we
have like maybe like three four five
years that's like the average amount of
time people spending university but
it goes by really really fast so
sometimes it feels like we have to cram
every second of it with like useful
things but
i think yeah it's all about finding a
compromise and you know as you said like
not doing
the same thing twice like trying not to
so that way you get a more varied
experience even though you have a really
limited time in
university so now that you know
what you want to do how do you make sure
that you actually get the job how do you
maximize
your chances of getting the interview
yeah so let's start off with talking
about our personal experiences of
our whole you know university job
application process
and i would say at the start i was
mainly focused on
applying for as many jobs as i can
because i wasn't really sure what i
wanted to do
but i think later on when i did realize
what i wanted to do i was a bit more
targeted with my approach
so one thing that really helped me
throughout my whole
job application process was linkedin and
i would use linkedin as a way for me to
see
not only what people ended up going into
after studying an information systems
degree but it also provided me a way to
be able to reach out to them and learn
more about what they did
so i tried to be as proactive as i could
towards the
final years of my university so that i
could
really understand what i wanted to do by
talking to people on
linkedin sending them a connection
request and having like a 30 minute
conversation with them
that i think was the biggest factor in
helping me land a job in a company and a
role that i was interested in
i was doing a lot of the preparation
before the actual
into and before the job application
process and i think that would
be what i would recommend to students as
well a big chunk of
figuring out what you want to do comes
way before
actually applying for the role it's kind
of like an ongoing process throughout
your time in university
i'm just laughing because you said that
you actually reached out to people and
like when i think from
from my perspective talking to people
this is not why i chose computer science
and being a software engineer but
well we sometimes have to do it uh so
with um
my experience i actually so
i started applying for jobs like i had
my first job before uni but it was more
of a luck like i actually walked into a
store and i was like
do you need anyone to work for you and
the guy was like
okay tell me more and i was i was fixing
laptops back then
um but then like at uni i was actually
applying i
like back then my dream was to work for
like big tech google microsoft or
whatever um so i applied
to google to microsoft and then two
smaller companies and that was kind of
my strategy whenever i would apply
i would always have kind of tier of
companies to which i applied which is
like my dream one
then my like second green one then
something maybe smaller maybe less known
and then like the last company would be
something that i don't know what would
have to happen for me not to get this
job
so what it what it gives you is that
you don't really worry as much and you
don't stress that much because you know
that you always have some fallback
um even if it's not your dream thing but
at least you know that you won't be left
without any job
and the big chances if you prepare like
lucy said
uh doing all your research beforehand
knowing how the interviews work you will
actually get your dream job
but without all of the stress that comes
with applying to just one place
yeah i really agree with that and i
think that's sort of my strategy as well
when i think back
um there were a few companies and roles
that i really really wanted but i always
sort of made sure that i had backup
plans in case things didn't work out
well
i could also go somewhere else for the
summer and even if it's not the role
that i wanted to go into
i can still use it as a way to talk to
people in the company
um and talk to people in the roles that
i was interested in so
i guess some experience is better than
having no experience at all
during the summer yeah it looks like a
logic yeah and then you get you also get
this experience on your cv so then
you graduate and suddenly they look at
like oh okay four internships that's
great
like you already have something you
already have an advantage
as a graduate yeah very very true so i
guess like in terms of like general
advice we have for
people in 2021 who want to um
maximize their chances of landing
interview i think my recommendation
would be
the same thing i mentioned earlier which
is trying to reach out to people on
linkedin
as many as you can honestly and try to
set up half an hour conversations with
them
because once you start building that
sort of relationship and you see a job
in a company
that they're working for that you might
be interested in i think what you can do
is maybe ask for a referral or maybe ask
them to connect you with someone
in that role so you can learn more about
it and once you do get to the interview
phase
you can sort of show all the knowledge
that you've gathered so that comes off
as you know being more prepared and yeah
whilst also maximizing your chances of
planning that
interview yeah and i think what it also
gives you is like all of those
soft skills that especially in 2021
companies are looking much more into
your values
uh your cultural fit so it's it's really
important to be like really open
uh have good communication skills take
feedback well which you can
also show during interviews so if you
have interviewers
hinting you a solution be open to it try
to explore it
and they are always trying to help you
and having that
that soft skills of being able to work
in kind of a team
that's really well looked at and if you
think about it
you are all graduates so you're starting
with just like expectations of like you
haven't worked
full time before so it's all about your
attitude that makes you different
from other people and one more thing to
add is to
always tailor your resume based on the
job that you're applying for
so read through the job description
focus on what the keywords are and try
to integrate the keywords into your
resume
have a look at what skills they prefer
and have a think about
how you've demonstrated those skills in
the past so that um your resume would be
a good fit for the role
instead of sending a generic resume out
to all the different companies
i think spending that extra time would
really help make a difference when it
comes to
getting that first interview okay so
moving on to the last part of the video
which is probably the part you're most
excited about
how to do well in an interview when
you've reached the interview stage
we're going to be breaking down this
part into two sections
first will be the technical interview
and the second part will be
the non-technical interview and i don't
have much experience with the technical
side of things so
i'm going to pass this to carol to kind
of talk about
what the interview involves and also
some tips on how to do well in that
technical interview
sure so how just how lucy mentioned
before
you have to do your homework so prepare
and know
how the technical interview looks in
every different company
you can find it on glassdoor you can
probably find it on reddit you can find
it definitely on youtube
just make sure that you know which type
it is the interviews in big tech
like google microsoft amazon apple they
are usually based
on lead code questions so to prepare for
this type of interview
practice data structures and
algorithmics and what you can do is
lead code catawares there's a lot of
websites when you can practice
and you get feedback straight away
because your code is run through some
tests
um there's a book called cracking the
coding interview
just read this whole book and do all the
problems in it and you're gonna get a
job
at big tech no problem but then there is
a new trend emerging
and that's something i like much more
which is the interviews are more
real life problems so that's how for
example my interview with canva looked
like i actually got a homework
which is creating some kind of app they
provided me a fake server
and then i had to create a couple of
features and because i was being hired
as an android engineer
i had to use all of the technologies and
frameworks
they were using and requiring at canva
so
i think now we should pass to lucy
because she has much more experience in
the more
soft skills related areas yeah so i can
talk a bit about the
behavioral side of things especially
because i've done tons and tons of
interviews
so i think the most important thing
before the interview is to really be
well prepared
um with maybe the sort of questions that
they might ask as carol mentioned
there's different websites that
sort of show you um what the classical
questions might be for a particular
company
and even if those questions don't end up
coming up in the interview
it would still help to prepare for them
so that if something similar comes along
you will be able to draw an experience
from an interview example that you
prepared earlier so
it always helps to be a bit more
prepared and to
try and um figure out what your skills
are
and learning how to communicate that to
the interviewer
and i think you know half an hour before
the interview is quite important
as well because you want to enter that
mind state where you're confident
and you want to show you know the best
side of you to the interviewer
so 30 minutes before an interview i
normally do my
power poses i would demonstrate how to
do power poses
anyways one more thing to keep in mind
is that the interviewer will always look
at your questions holistically
and the impression that you give it's
not really about the individual
questions
so if you you know stuff up one question
and didn't really answer it to the best
of your abilities just
um don't let that one question kind of
stop you from
doing well in the rest of your
interviews and i'll say the same thing
for technical interviews right yeah
totally
uh just don't really worry about it
because when you do the technical
interviews
you are not expected to get everything
hundred percent right
it's more of your thinking process
that's being
uh i don't want to say judged what's a
good word for that oh
assessed yeah yes yes so that's your
ability to
think logically to solve problems that's
what's being assessed
so also don't don't worry about it
because if your process
of getting the answers right even if you
didn't the answer
fast enough or perfect enough or in the
best
time complexity don't worry about it you
can still get the job so don't get
discouraged just keep up keep going
through all the other questions
nice yeah i think we've covered some
really important points and maybe just
to wrap up
you know um when you've reached that
final interview stage you went through
the whole interview
um what would you recommend doing to
like follow up with the interviewer
because i think normally i would send
like you know thank you email to
thank them for their time is that
something that you recommend doing as
well
i have never done that myself okay
i was always waiting uh for the answer
what i would say
is maybe if they don't contact you
follow up if they contact you with
rejection
also remember to follow up ask for
feedback ask for what
what could i improve what would make me
one percent better
and yeah that's something because also
remember
if you apply to a place once to to a
company once and they reject you it
doesn't mean
that you can never apply again you can
apply again usually in half a year
and then if they see the whole process
because they have files on you
uh if they see the whole process of you
learning and trying to improve that's
already
a huge advantage yeah that's the point i
completely forgot about because i just
thought about you know thanking the
interviewer or the recruiter for their
time but it's really important as well
to follow up to
you know if you don't get in just ask
for feedback and try to be proactive and
figure out what
you went wrong in so that in the future
when you apply again
you can improve on that and increase
your chances so
this brings us to the end of this video
let us know if you want to see more
videos like this and don't forget to
check out the video we have on carol's
channel
talking about the difference between
computer science and information systems
that's it for now please remember to
like and subscribe and we'll see you
next time
bye for now